ông vũ Minh châu, chú tương nghiệp vàng bảo tín Minh châu, cùng con trai là vũ Minh chú và 2 nhân viên kế toán bị khởi tố với cáu bộ, đi phạm quy định về kế toán.
Theo cáu bộ, chức lâm hành hình không chăm hai tư, ông châu và tủ chỉ đạo kế toán dùng 2 hệ thống phần mềm để khoản lý kinh giói người và kế khai thủy.
Tư nụ ở nắm hành hình không chăm hai tư đến nay để tránh bị kếm chà, ông châu bị cho là chỉ đạo sóa khẳng bộ giữ liệu trên phần mềm hí vì con,
rồi chuyển sang dụng Excel và phần mềm bán hàng Fox AI.
Tư giữ liệu chỉ xuất trên phần mềm hí vì, dài đoạn hành hình không chăm hai mềm hình không chăm hai ba.
Tư quan đều chá mức đầu xác định, dưỡng thú thực tế của công ty chắc nghiệm hiểu hạn bảo tính mình châu khoảng 18 in bài chăm tý đồng.
Trên gần chính in bài chăm tý đồng, sau với số đạo bảo cáu thuế.
Số tiền thiệt hại trong nân xách nhả nước, ước khoảng 18 năm 18 đồng.
Tư giữ liệu hạn bảo tính mình châu, tại phố trên nhân tông và câu dễ thả nội.
Sau khiến bún dở như thông tây liệu nghiệm phong được đưa rằng hả?
Bảo tính mình châu, thành lật 5 in chính trong chính mình lâm, là một thương dự vàng lớn ở Hanoi.
Xoanh nghiệp hiện có bún cơ sở tại Hanoi và hơn 2 chăm đại li trên bọn quốc.
Hàng ngày các hợp hằng nón tiếp hành trong lợt khách đến sau dịch, cạnh dòng người sẽ hằng giến ra thử xuyên.
Theo cộng thung tiền cút ra về đăng kỹ xoanh nghiệp, tính đến ngày 20 xa thân một, công ty có vốn điều lệ bún trong tý đồng.
Ông vụ mình châu, nắm hơn chính mới bài phần chăm của phần.